[Musique]
qui êtes-vous Éléonore Roosevelt
documentaire réalisé par Patrick Jedi
l'épouse de Franklin d'Elano Roosevelt
était vous venez de le voir une femme
libre et engagée et en plein marasme
économique qu'elle a donné une dimension
politique sans précédent à une First
Lady américaine au point de devenir
l'égérie d'une nouvelle génération de
femmes désireuses de se forger une place
dans un monde politique alors
exclusivement réservé aux hommes de quoi
s'interroger après ce film sur
l'influence jusqu'à nos jours des
premières dames américaines sur leur
président de Marie et bien c'est ce que
nous allons faire maintenant avec nos
deux invités présente aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau de débat doc en commençant par
vous Nicole Bachard en bienvenue vous
êtes politologue spécialiste de la
société américaine on vous doit entre
autres first ladies un ouvrage que vous
avez co écrit avec le journaliste
Dominique Simonnet publié chez Perrin et
réédité en poche chez tampus quant à
votre le dernier livre plus personnel
celui-ci il puisqu'il mêle l'intrigue
gros manège que et votre propre
cheminement sur les traces de votre mère
il s'intitule la plus résistante de
toutes c'est tout chaud il est
disponible chez Stock et puis également
avec nous Hélène artère bienvenue à vous
vous êtes historienne professeur
d'histoire contemporaine à l'université
parisien Panthéon Sorbonne spécialiste
de l'Amérique du Nord et directrice
d'ailleurs du centre de recherche
d'histoire
nord-américaine vous êtes par ailleurs
présidente du Comité pour l'histoire du
CNRS dont le président en horaire n’est
autre André kasfi hein qu'on en profite
pour le salut au passage c'est un fidèle
de cette émission votre dernier livre
s'intitule de lui Jacky Kennedy un
destin américain un ouvrage publié aux
éditions calibre on va bien sûr parler
de la reine Jackie c'est comme ça qu'on
a dénommé dans cette émission nicole
Bacharan question simple mais après ce
documentaire on a envie de vous la poser
tout de suite qu'y a-t-il un avant et un
après et la Nord Roosevelt dans ce rôle
de First Lady américaine
c'est un rôle parce que cette fonction
n'existe pas aux yeux de la Constitution
américaine un avant et un après le Nord
Roosevelt dans ce rôle on peut dire les
choses comme ça ou alors est-ce que ce
documentaire est un petit peu
à l'avantage d'Hélène simplement la prêt
n'est pas forcément venue tout de suite
je pense que les first les villes qui
l'ont immédiatement suivi madame Truman
madame maizenhower ont été des modèles
de firstleyde un petit peu d'avant et
mais en or Roosevelt mais néanmoins
Éléonore Roosevelt elle a elle a fait
des petites et non pas des des petits
c'est vrai que Jackie Kennedy elle n'en
parlera certainement très très bien sans
être du tout sur le modèle militant
social de elenor Roosevelt a pris un
rôle notamment au niveau culturel au
niveau automatique au niveau médiatique
qui était beaucoup plus ambitieux au
fond que c'est que les first lady's
qu'il avait précédé et puis je pense que
vraiment la vraie enfant de Hélène
roosevelton et souvenez-vous d'ailleurs
qu'il y avait eu des polémiques parce
que Hillary Clinton disait qu'elle
parlait avec Éléonore Roosevelt alors
que non elle n'était pas devenue folle
elle ne hanter pas les couverts la nuit
mais c'était un dialogue intérieur avec
une femme qui l'a beaucoup inspiré
c'est-à-dire comment être une femme
libre comment être une militante des
causes qui l'intéressait comment être
l'épouse du président comment faire
avancer ce qu'elle pensait juste en
matière d'agenda politique je suis sûr
qu'on en reparlera ensemble mais il est
avec Clinton a essuyé beaucoup de
déconvenues en tant que petite fille ou
arrière petite fille de Elena Roosevelt
hélas Roosevelt grande bourgeoise mais
vous l'avez dit très impliqué sur le
terrain féministe militant juste une
précision par rapport aux documentaire
convenable elle était aussi bisexuelle
elle est en or Roosevelt elle a une
période avec une compagne femme c'est ce
qu'on nous laisse entendre ce film mais
c'est pas dit comme ça vous nous le
confirmez
complètement et c'est vrai que ça a été
une jeune fille d'un milieu très très
bourgeois et très corseté il faut bien
le dire elle a fait un mariage très
traditionnel avec son cousin Franklin
Roosevelt elle a été une bonne épouse
soumise à la belle-mère qui était un
dragon une nouvelle rassemble à bien
compris dans ce film elle a eu cinq
enfants elle a eu cette déception
amoureuse vraiment très profonde que le
infliger son son mari il me semble que
d'une certaine manière elle s'est
retirée de la vie amoureuse jusqu'au
moment où beaucoup plus libre elle a eu
des liaisons avec des amis des des
femmes où elle s'est beaucoup plus
épanouie et tout ça était de notoriété
publique à l'époque ou public ça lui a
valu un certain nombre de critiques en
privé dans un le cercle du pouvoir
j'imagine c'était le cas il y a eu des
rumeurs voilà incontestables et dans le
milieu en particulier dans le milieu
washingtonien parce que il y a quand
même un décalage extrêmement fort entre
ce que le public c'est est-ce que les
gens qui tournent autour de la Maison
Blanche ça et ça nous renvoie quand même
à une question fondamentale pour
compléter c'est la question de la
médiatisation c'est à dire que cette
médiatisation de la famille
présidentielle elle va connaître une
accélération extrêmement forte dans ces
années là ça intéressant de se rendre
compte que Hollywood part au parlant à
la fin des années 20 et donc finalement
nous sommes à une époque où nous
entendons et nous voyons en simultané
ces hommes et ces femmes qui sont au
cœur du pouvoir et moi j'ai trouvé très
émouvant d'entendre dans ce dans ce
reportage ces images où on voit Éléonore
Roosevelt qui se déplace qui se me qui
va beaucoup en déplacement à l'étranger
et qui parlent c'est d'ailleurs que on a
cette capacité à entendre la voix de
l'épouse du président alors que jusque
là finalement c'était une personne qu'on
photographiée mais c'était pas forcément
une personne qu'on entendait donc une
forme d'autonomisation finalement
médiatisation
néanmoins il y a peut-être un élément
très très important à dire pour
peut-être compléter ce que vous venez de
dire est-ce que dit dans le documentaire
elle se déplace beaucoup elle va voir ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les invisibles
de la société américaine de l'époque les
Noirs les pauvres elle prend la défense
des des syndicats des femmes
mais il y a peut-être une raison
particulière à ça avec Franklin d'Hélène
Roosevelt c'est un handicapé alors
évidemment vous parlez de communication
tout a été fait pour ne pas mettre en
avant ce handicap du président américain
mais elle était ses yeux ses oreilles
mais aussi surtout ses jambes c'est le
cas non tout à fait je rajouterais
d'ailleurs par rapport au documentaires
qu'en fait sa conscience sociale n'est à
la fin des années 90 elle fait un grand
tour en Europe elle est scolarisée
Grande Bretagne dans une école qui
dirigée par une femme qui s'appelle
madame Souvestre et c'est cette madame
Souvestre qui va l'ouvrir finalement à
la condition des des plus pauvres et des
plus défavorisés et quand elle revient à
New York donc on est sur la première
décennie du 20e elle va s'engager dans
ce qu'on appelle et cet Allemand c'est à
dire ces lieux où elle va faire de
l'humanité servir la soupe aider les
immigrants etc donc finalement elle a
une conscience qui est là l'attente et
c'est évidemment ce qui va se passer
dans l'antre de guerre qui va la
développer mais ça ne part pas de
totalement rien donc c'est une femme
vraiment convaincue qui va aider
Franklin dans son parcours politique et
va l'ouvrir vers les milieux qui on
dirait plus à gauche aujourd'hui elle
représentait l'aile gauche
du président américain
c'est pas un jeu politique elle joue
elle est vraiment convaincue depuis de
très nombreuses années de formation de
la Genèse que c'est quelque chose
d'important il a été dit beaucoup de
choses sur la norme Roosevelt dans ce
film néanmoins il y a des choses à dire
en plus des choses qu'on n'aurait pas pu
dans ce documentaire il y a eu toute sa
vie après la mort de Franklin Roosevelt
et notamment son rôle au moment de
l'adoption de la Charte Internationale
des Droits de l'Homme aux Nations Unies
elle lui a participé je crois qu'on peut
dire qu'elle en a été la marraine et
quand ça a été adopté elle a reçu une
stand dégovation totalement
improbable pour une fausse Lady elle
n'était plus la force elle était
vraiment une femme très impliquée dans
dans les questions de des droits de
l'homme et elle a eu d'ailleurs des
funérailles nationales ce qui est là
aussi tout à fait inhabituel pour une
facialise donc elle a eu une autre vie
ensuite mais dans la droite ligne de ce
qu'elle avait fait précédemment il est
dit aussi dans ce film que certains la
poussaient après la mort de de son mari
en avril 45 à elle-même se présentait à
la Maison Blanche
est-ce qu'il y a une tentation de sa
part de le faire ou
ça n'a jamais été le cas même si
certains lui poussait alors c'est une
femme qui a écrit aussi je crois que
c'est quand même particulier d'être une
farce Lady qui raconte sa vie et avec
des mémoires qui sont extrêmement qui
deviennent des best-sellers donc elle a
un premier livre en 37 ma vie et elle
est écrit après la mort de Franklin oui
il y a eu des gens qui l'ont poussé mais
je crois qu'il faut rappeler que le
contexte politique de l'époque ne s'y
prêtait pas il y a un occupant à la
Maison Blanche qui s'appelle Harry
Truman et qui compte bien rester à la
maison blanche il y a des ambitions
politiques aussi bien du parti au sein
du parti démocrate que du parti
républicain et la société américaine
très clairement n'est pas mûr pour pour
cette option à ce moment-là je crois que
maintenant on est pas sur nous on n'est
pas sûr non plus mais c'était encore
pire en 1945 voilà ça faisait pas partie
des choses vraiment envisageables bon il
n'y a pas de fonction officielle
il y a une ligne budgétaire il y a une
ligne budgétaire
est officiel chaque année dans le budget
il y a une ligne budgétaire qui concerne
l'affaire ses activités sont staff etc
alors c'est un rôle dont je dirais qu'il
est quand même un peu plus officiel
qu'en France souvenez-vous que le
président Macron avait tenté de donner
un rôle officiel à la firs asafirst Lady
et que ça a été levé de bouclier donc ça
n'a pas été possible donc c'est un peu
plus officiel aux États-Unis mais ça
reste quand même un rôle très ingrat
mais elles sont jamais assez bien
honnêtement elles sont ou trop frivoles
ont pas assez chic ou trop présent c'est
tout à fait ça et en fait quand on
regarde finalement ça commence dès la
première on leur demande tout est là
le contraire et depuis madame Washington
on a des attentes extrêmement fortes
alors pour avoir travaillé sur Jacky
mais aussi pour avoir travaillé sur
Madame Eisen
le soutien famille de militaire et donc
du coup elle ne
rencontre pas d'échecs politiques elle
porte pas des lois des projets qui
pourraient échouer et puis elle n'ont
pas comme en général c'est le cas aux
États-Unis la moitié du pays pour eux
l'autre moitié contre c'est quand même
plus large donc elles sont plus
populaires c'est j'en profite pour
rajouter sur cette question ce qui est
vrai un qui a fait débat au début du
mandat de du premier mandat d'Emmanuel
Macron sur le statut de la première dame
Brigitte Macron ne dispose d'aucun
statut officiel ça a été tranché
évidemment mais néanmoins elle dispose
comme c'est le cas de les faire du bien
américaine d'un cabinet il est composé
en France de deux collaborateurs
partagés avec le chef de l'État ainsi
que de deux assistantes à mi-temps et la
Cour des comptes
dans un rapport d'ailleurs
à annoncé que les dépenses liées à ce
cabinet dédié à Brigitte Macron
s'élevait
292000 euros en 2021 ça représente 0,5%
du budget de la Présidence de la
République française
je voulais vous demander autre chose sur
un autre terrain et là on a entre
l'influence politique et
l'influence au sein d'un couple qui peut
avoir une femme par rapport à son
compagnon vous dites dans votre livre la
First Lady est celle qui dit la vérité
souvent la seule à le faire et c'est
précisément là que se situe son premier
pouvoir vous êtes d'accord avec ça il y
a des firts ils disent américaine qui
ont eu une influence toute particulière
auprès de leur président de Marie parce
que c'était les seuls à pouvoir ne pas
jouer le jeu de la cour présidentiel ce
qui appelait d'ailleurs
Jackie Kennedy la blanchite la Maison
Blanche la Maison Blanche oui alors
après je pense que ça tient au contexte
le documentaire montre bien qu'il est le
nom Roosevelt a de l'influence sur les
questions sociétales à partir du moment
où les questions sociétales reculent
avec la Seconde Guerre mondiale elle
devient quasiment invisible mais on voit
bien si on reprend que finalement ce
qu'on aurait pu dire déjà c'est que la
Maison Blanche est un lieu où on vit
c'est à dire que très concrètement la
famille présidentielle est installée à
la Maison Blanche et donc si je prends
le cas d'Eisenhower que je maîtrise un
petit peu mieux
et ben c'est une vie de famille normale
donc le couple présidentiel le président
la première personne qu'il voit le matin
surtout quand ils ne trompe pas sa femme
c'est sa femme et la dernière personne
qui voit le soir c'est son épouse donc
dans l'intimité bah évidemment le
conjoint est celui et ça elle puisque ce
ne sont que des femmes qui peuvent
parler en toute liberté à leur mari pour
leur dire ça ça va lâche moins convaincu
là tu es dans l'erreur etc après tout
dépend de la relation que le couple a on
voit bien que sur le couple Eisenhower
qui est un coupe fusionnelle il se parle
chez les Kennedy on comprend très bien
que évidemment la le poids de la parole
de Jacky sur son mari n'est pas
exactement la même donc il y a cette
relation qui est plus ou moins
différente et on pourrait dire la même
chose chez les Carter le couple Carter
est un couple extrêmement proche où
Madame Carter est une femme qui
s'investit dans beaucoup de dossiers
parfois trop lui reproche-t-on à
l'époque déjà donc voilà il y a cette
dimension quand même d'une d'une
intimité qui fait qu'on peut parler à
son conjoint alors que évidemment un
ministre peut se sentir
cette dimension de l'intimité du couple
dans le la répartition des rôles même si
institutionnellement on l'a dit il y a
pas de il y a pas de débat mais
dans l'intimité il y a des couples vous
n'avez pas cité le couple régal il
semble aussi même si regarde et en
grande partie contre les conseillers
avec affaire avec Nancy régal et très
honnêtement quand on examine
la trajectoire de se faire sliders on
voit que l'entourage politique du
président très souvent ils en ont plus
cassé de la faire parce que justement
elle est la première le matin la
dernière le soir et que bon il y a des
couples qui se parlent à peine mais ceux
qui se parlent et ceux qui sont très
proches ben oui elle a elle a une
influence parce que elle elle ne sera
pas renvoyée elle a pas peur pour sa
place elle a pas elle le connaît souvent
depuis qu'ils sont très jeunes enfin là
on a vu en France une force Lady ils ont
temporaire qui a été renvoyé mais
normalement
elle va garder sa place jusqu'à la fin
mais il y en a qui qui nous guère
d'influence sur leur mari qui sont
franchement maltraités je pense à Pat
Nixon l'épouse Richard Nixon qui
vraiment a enduré le martyr au côté de
son mari et pour laquelle il avait
vraiment très très peu de considération
donc
voilà il y a des couples intimes parce
qu'on au fond conquérir la Maison
Blanche c'est une affaire de couple avec
toute la médiatisation il faut que
l'épouse soit là mais pour certains
heureusement d'ailleurs pour eux il y a
une complicité qui va au-delà de l'image
la reine Jackie Kennedy elle a souvent
été surnommée comme cela Jacky Kennedy
c'est c'est la firt Lady qui plus près
la lumière
oui mais qui est très malheureuse à la
Maison Blanche c'est à dire que elle
estime que c'est une prison quelle est
la comme dans un aquarium tout le monde
la regarde tout le monde l'observe il
faut dire aussi qu'il y a un défilé de
maîtresse de son mari jusque dans la
chambre conjugale donc ça n'aide pas
totalement à être en harmonie et
finalement qui essaye de s'enfuir de la
Maison Blanche dès que dès que c'est
possible donc c'est toute l'ambiguïté
entre la communication présidentielle ce
qu'on retient et sa manière à elle de
vivre son rôle de première dame ce qui
est quand même assez particulier c'est
que c'est une femme qui refuse par
exemple les interviews enfin on a du mal
à imaginer que aujourd'hui l'épouse d'un
président soit chiche de sa parole ça
paraît totalement inimaginable mais elle
elle est dans cette position très
particulière et c'est le silence qui
crée d'une certaine manière le mystère
et qui fait que on projette sur Jacky
Kennedy toutes sortes de choses après
pour rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit
très justement Jacky Kennedy c'est aussi
la rénovation de la maison blanche c'est
toute cette
documentaire et cette émission télévisée
ou entièrement consacrée d'ailleurs à
cette visite de la Maison Blanche
rénover donc c'est vraiment
l'incarnation politique on va dire de la
culture du bon goût de ce qu'est
l'Amérique moderne des années 60 qui est
une Amérique jeune on le rappelle qui a
été considérablement rajeuni par le
baby-boom notamment et Jacky Kennedy
l'incarne cette genèse d'une femme
élégante avec de jeunes enfants le bon
goût la culture et qui se veut une
rupture finalement avec les années 50
est-ce qu'elle a réussi à éclipser par
moment
John Fitzgerald Kennedy ça a été le cas
semble-t-il lors de sa visite en Europe
la fameuse et notamment
il se présente en disant je suis le
monsieur qui accompagne
Jacky Jacky Kennedy c'est un tout c'est
vrai que c'est voilà ils étaient
tellement jeunes tellement beaux
tellement chic avec des enfants
tellement merveilleux défendant des
bonnes causes d'une certaine manière
c'est une vision de la mairie que
généreuse tournée vers l'avenir à
laquelle chacun avait je crois envie de
croire et puis je pense qu'aussi sa
place dans l'histoire malheureusement
c'est le fruit du drame c'est un destin
tragique les Kennedy même elle n'a pas
vécu très âgée son fils est mort peu de
temps après avec sa jeune femme et sa
belle-sœur on s'en souvient dans un
accident d'avion bon Bobby Kennedy
évidemment donc il y a une marque du
tragique qui font qui fait que les
Kennedy c'est une espèce d'âge d'or le
fameux Kaamelott mais qu'elle voulait
incarner
éternellement jeune était éternellement
beau donc ils font toujours rêver
de Gilles Biden
le tout nouveau président des États-Unis
mais ancien vice-président bien entendu
Jill Biden est-ce qu'elle influence
réellement son son mari de président
elle est enseignante elle aussi très
impliquée sur les questions
d'enseignement de santé semble-t-il
l'influence de Jil Biden sur Joe Biden
c'est ce qu'on peut en dire une
personnalité qui est une évidence
manifeste sur son mari et c'est là qu'on
voit aussi que le temps a changé
puisqu'on ne se pose pas la question de
est-ce légitime ou est-ce illégitime
parce que finalement elle est là elle
incarne quelque chose et ça paraît pour
les médias américains une forme
d'évidence
l'arrivée à une position d'une femme qui
est là qui est à côté de son mari mais
qui a aussi un agenda propre vous l'avez
rappelé très justement sur les questions
d'éducation donc voilà c'est un couple
ah oui c'est vrai on est dans ce schéma
évoqué tout à l'heure d'un couple qui se
tient c'est la première force la vie qui
travaille oui en dehors de la maison
blanche pour un salaire certainement pas
très important parce que c'est vraiment
du temps partiel mais elle a gardé ses
fonctions d'enseignante c'est une
professeur d'anglais et très souvent
auprès d'enfants qui ont des difficultés
particulières et elle est absolument
passionnée par son par son métier elle a
exercé tout le temps ou Joe Biden était
vice-président et elle continue à
l'exercer aujourd'hui et là je trouve
qu'un parallèle avec Brigitte Macron ses
enseignantes passionnés qui ne renoncent
pas tout à fait et je trouve ça très
moderne pour le coup et en plus elle est
pleinement dans la société c'est à dire
qu'il y a pas cette déconnexion avec le
monde voilà je connais alors peut-être
rappeler aussi un match dans l'opinion
américaine lors des dernières élections
entre Melania Trump qui présentait un
profil tout autre et Jill Biden elle
représente deux visions de femme
américaine rappelez-vous la campagne
entre madame bouche et Madame Clinton
voilà une faisait des recettes c'était
le concours donc on est vraiment quand
même sur deux incarnations différentes
de ce qui a le ouais une nuit à Mélanie
Trump outre son mari franchement mais
c'est le fait qu'elle avait l'air
tellement de s'embêter
elle faisait la tête tout le temps elle
a pas aimé cette fonction de première
dame et la pas essayer d'en faire
quelque chose les autres ma foi des fois
elle réussissent des fois elles échouent
mais elles essayent grâce à la notoriété
qui est la leur de faire avancer une
cause ou une autre mais alors vraiment
Mélania Trump un ennui total quoi elle
n'aimait pas c'est peut-être aussi dire
aussi qu'il y a une forme de concurrence
parce qu'on voit bien dans le
documentaire que il y a madame Roosevelt
mais il y a aussi sa fille qui est
extrêmement présente et dans le cas des
Trump il y a yvanka qui est quand même
extrêmement présente et si on suit la
couverture médiatique aujourd'hui c'est
Ivanka dans David après alors si on
comprend bien elle a lâché dans les
loisirs les voyages etc mais c'est vrai
que ça a été une figure centrale de la
présidence Trump qui finalement a
éclipsé sa belle-mère d'une certaine
manière
continuons notre passage en vue de
certaines personnes
Michel Obama première firt Lady noir
américain
qui a eu des débuts difficiles qui
étaient même moqué je crois au début de
de son entrée à la Maison Blanche
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de du bilan de
Michel Obama qu'est-ce qu'elle a apporté
en plus la telle seulement fait dans ce
rôle de faire clédier américaine moi je
crois qu'on peut dire que c'est une
réussite totale vraiment une réussite
totale et vous avez raison de dire qu'au
début elle a eu du mal un peu pendant la
campagne électorale surtout on leur
projet de dire des moqueries sur son
mari avec la volonté de le rendre plus
humain moins professoral en quelque
sorte
on l'a fait le procès alors dans
certains milieux évidemment d'une de ces
femmes noires à poil qui mènent son
homme à la baguette et il faut dire que
pendant tout le temps où elle est à la
Maison Blanche elle a fait l'objet de
critiques et datacie d'une violence
incroyable mais pour disons le tout
venant de l'opinion c'est une femme qui
vraiment a eu à coeur de montrer un
autre visage de l'Amérique noire la
légitimité totale de cette famille noire
magnifique d'ailleurs à la Maison
Blanche qui n'a jamais fait de faux pas
ou alors des vraiment minimaux par
rapport ne pas gêner son mari ça quand
même toujours été son ambition première
qui a adopté ses causes consensuelles
soutient en famille de militaire lutte
contre l'obésité la mauvaise
alimentation
le sport etc mais avec une espèce de de
générosité d'enthousias rythme
d'intelligence politique qui ont fait
qui ont fait des merveilles et je me
souviens de ça prestation je terminerai
là-dessus mais à la seconde investiture
de son mari comme comme candidat donc en
2012 pour un deuxième mandat c'était
elle la star de la de la convention elle
était d'une élégance folle elle a
prononcé des discours avec ce mélange de
spontanéité très travaillée et de et de
sérieux ça a été une magnifique faire
c'est je trouve un échelle Obama
tellement star peut-être à ce moment-là
que beaucoup
prédisent déjà qu'elle se présentera la
Maison Blanche et la sortie un certain
temps d'ouvrage aussi Michel Obama les
médiatiquement aujourd'hui très présente
elle continue de faire des tournées et
c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui est
qui a réussi à être populaire au-delà du
Parti démocrate oui finalement installer
une forme de normalité à la Maison
Blanche d'une famille parce que on l'a
rappelé c'est un couple mais c'est aussi
une famille à la Maison Blanche quand il
y a des jeunes enfants qui ressemblent à
des tas de famille avec les adolescents
qui grandissent et leurs problèmes
là récemment elle expliquait combien les
premières années du mariage avaient été
difficiles parce que les enfants
l'occupaient beaucoup et son mari
s'occupaient peu des enfants donc donc
finalement elle parle de choses qui
parlent à des millions d'Américains qui
se reconnaissent dans cette expérience
particulière et là Clinton Hillary
Clinton c'est la seule à cette présentée
à la présidence des États-Unis elle a
échoué très peu finalement en 2016 voilà
c'est la seule
après avoir été faire Teddy durant deux
mandats avec son mari Bill Clinton et
dans des conditions pas de jour facile
pour le plan intime justement tous les
plans mais je pense que les first League
qui ont passé 4 ans 8 ans à la Maison
Blanche la plupart d'entre elles a
commencé par Michel Obama on leur parle
de se présenter elle part en courant
c'est une expérience qui est vraiment
très très dure sur le plan personnel et
sur le plan politique mais Hillary
Clinton c'est l'exception elle a été
comment dire elle était certainement non
pas plus brillante mais elle avait des
dons différents de ceux de son mari lui
c'était vraiment le candidat dans toute
sa splendeur avec un style extraverti
chaleureux doué pour ça et elle c'était
vraiment la la femme construite avec un
programme hyper précise hyper bosseuse
et on l'a souvent dit sous la forme de
plaisanterie mais je crois que c'est
assez après il n'aurait jamais pu être
président sans elle mais
entre entre elle et lui je pense que
c'est la réalité je pense il lui a été
extrêmement
bien se traiter mais il est très
reconnaissant de toute l'aide qu'elle
lui apportait pour lui c'était naturel
que Hillary ensuite et son tour c'est la
triste de New York première dame et
ensuite présidente oui c'est et moi je
trouve intéressant cette candidature au
Sénat de New York qui n'est pas évidente
puisque finalement elle est dans une
circonscription qui n'est pas forcément
acquise ou démocrate ça rappelle
d'ailleurs le le parcours de Robert
Kennedy élu aussi au Sénat et qui
représente New York avec une femme aussi
qu'elle produit d'une époque il faut se
rappeler que elle fait ses études dans
ce moment particulier des années 60 avec
une militance politique qui ressemble
beaucoup à celle d'Éléonore Roosevelt et
finalement c'est peut-être l'époque qui
a fait que
c'est son mari qui a été élu c'est elle
arrivait peut-être un petit peu tôt et
que tous les deux on les compétences
pour être président des États-Unis alors
ce qui lui manque c'est qu'évidemment
elle a été très décrié on l'a pas évoqué
mais elle fait partie des seuls forcées
qui ont porté un projet politique la
fameuse réforme de la santé et
rétrospectivement beaucoup d'Américains
sont encore braqués sur sur cette échec
au responsabilité tout à fait vous
voulez évidemment aborder
le cas d'une peut-être d'une future
présidente des États-Unis c'est là que
notre aujourd'hui notre siège sont les
premières les premières dames
américaines mais demain on aura
peut-être à évoquer les premiers hommes
américains alors il y a Kamala à risque
qui vise présidente des États-Unis son
mari d'ailleurs s'appelle Douglas amov
et on le sait le deuxième gentilhomme
des États-Unis c'est l'étiquette
officieuse qu'on lui donne officiel
voilà ma question c'est de savoir si on
aura demain
pour une femme sur la première marche du
podium écoutez je ne sais pas si ce sera
comme la Harris mais j'espère que ça
arrivera un jour et que ce sera la
meilleure la plus qualifiée celle qui
fera le plus beau parcours mais elle
aura besoin certainement à ses côtés
d'un compagnon qui la soutiennent qui
sache qui sachent trouver sa place de
Game of son mari tente de le faire il a
renoncé à son cabinet d'avocat il a un
poste d'enseignant à Georget Stan mais
pas tant pas à temps plein et il
s'engage sur certaines causes comme
notamment la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme si je peux me permettre
une présidente femme à la tête des
États-Unis c'est à une échéance assez
proche alors évidemment on lit pas dans
les boules de cristal néanmoins
de la société américaine
donc c'est une évolution normale mais en
tout cas sur le rôle de seconde
gentleman c'est le terme qu'on emploie
aux États-Unis on voit très bien que
voilà
il y a une force bien ça se passe bien
c'est naturel et donc tout naturellement
cette fonction pourrait se transformer
en premier gentleman là je crois qu'il y
a il y a aucun problème d'acceptation de
ce que doit être le rôle du conjoint de
celui ou de celle qui est président des
États-Unis donc voilà l'avenir de le
dire mais voilà ce sera son titre ça
sera premier gentleman
il y a aucun problème en la matière on
est habitué à avoir
l'époux de la vice-présidente qui est
dans un rôle et qui a l'air à l'aise
dans ce rôle il a pas l'air frustré
c'est la fin de cette émission vraiment
un grand merci à toutes les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc aujourd'hui
pour évoquer bien entendu
le rôle la place
occupé par les first ladies américaines
après ce formidable documentaire
consacré à la mort Roosevelt et signé
par Patrick juvis vos réactions ça sera
sur hashtag débadoc sur Twitter merci
aussi à sel massalik qui m'a aidé comme
à la coutumée à préparer cette émission
et puis je vous donne tout simplement
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]